- Welcome back to Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation.
My name is John Watrous, and
I'm the Technical Director for IBM Quantum Education.
This is the fourth lesson of the series and it's the final
lesson in the first unit of the series on the basics
of quantum information.
Thus far, we've talked about
how quantum information works for both single and multiple systems, we've taken a look at the
quantum circuit model,
and we've observed some
fundamental limitations on quantum information.
Along the way, we
encountered some important mathematical concepts
including tensor products and inner products, and we'll continue
to make use of those concepts and we'll introduce some new
ones as well as we need them.
In this lesson, we'll be
focusing on three fundamental important examples, quantum teleportation, superdense coding and the CHSH game,
which is also called the CHSH inequality and not always described as a game.
These are not just random
examples meant to illustrate how quantum information works, they really are key
parts of the foundation
of quantum information and
they arise in different and sometimes unexpected settings within quantum information
and computation.
Entanglement plays a key role in all three of these
examples, and in fact, it's entanglement that makes them work
and makes them interesting. So, this lesson will, in some sense, be our first opportunity to
see entanglement in action
and to begin to explore what it is that makes entanglement so interesting.
The overview for the
lesson is very simple, we'll go one by one
through the three examples that I just mentioned,
quantum teleportation,
superdense coding, and the CHSH game.
We'll discuss what these things are and what makes them interesting and we'll go through analyses that explain exactly how they work
at a mathematical level.
Before we get to the first
of the three examples, which is quantum teleportation, it's appropriate to first
introduce the characters,
Alice and Bob, in case you're
not familiar with them.
Alice and and Bob, are names
given to hypothetical entities or agents in systems, protocols, games,
and really any other type of interaction you might wish to consider that involves the exchange of information.
They first arose in the
context of cryptography in the 1970s, but the
convention to use these names in this way has become very common
in a much broader context since then. The idea is that these
are very common names, at least in some parts of the world, and they start with the letters A and B,
and it's also convenient
to refer to Alice and Bob using the pronouns, her and him just for the sake of brevity.
We typically imagine that Alice and Bob are in different locations and that they have different
goals and different behaviors
depending upon whatever it is that we're talking about.
For example, if we're
talking about communication, meaning, the transmission of information, then we might decide
that Alice is the sender
and Bob is the receiver
of whatever information is being transmitted.
Sometimes Alice and Bob
cooperate, that's very typical, but sometimes they
compete or they might have different goals that may
or may not be consistent
with one another, but this
all has to be made clear in the situation at hand.
Of course, they represent abstractions and not necessarily actual human beings.
We can also introduce
additional characters such as Charlie and
Diane or different names that represent different
personas such as Eve
for an Eves Strapper or Mallory for someone behaving maliciously
depending upon the setting.
In any case, we will see Alice and Bob in all three of the
examples that we'll discuss in this lesson and from time to time
throughout the remainder of the series. I'll also make a few
comments about entanglement before moving on to the three examples.
In lesson two, we encounter this example of an entangled state of two Qubits.
It's one of the four bell states, and you could say that
this particular state represents the archetypal example
of an entangled quantum state.
We also encountered this
example of a probabilistic state of two bits.
It's analogous to the
entangled state in some sense, but it's not entangled,
entanglement is a uniquely
quantum phenomenon,
essentially by definition.
There is a precise mathematical definition of what entanglement is and basically what that definition
says is that entanglement
is a non-classical quantum correlation.
But that's not all that
helpful at an intuitive level, it's a definition of entanglement in terms of what entanglement isn't,
and it's probably for that
reason that it's sexually pretty difficult to explain what entanglement is and what makes it special
in intuitive terms.
When people do try to
explain what entanglement is in intuitive terms, you
often hear explanations that really don't
distinguish these two states
in a meaningful way. You may hear the idea
that if you measure one of the two entangled Qubits,
then the state of the other one